und über diese fläschchen natürlich noch
ein bisschen länger zu sprechen denn da
gibt es ein bisschen positive nachricht
heute abend nämlich dass beyond tagwerk
in marburg das neue werk das hat jetzt
endlich die zulassung wirklich los
produzieren zu können peter das heißt
wann wird das erste dieser fläschchen
dieses neue werk in marburg verlassen
wenn alles klappt noch im februar
wahrscheinlich mitte februar können kann
bei und trägt mit der massenproduktion
in marburg beginnen das ist wirklich
eine gute nachricht ein kleines wörtchen
kann man mal vom himmel ziehen
es kommt ein wenig sonnenschein ein
wenig und fanden so kleine paket vom hof
oder ist das großer stilvolle fläschchen
das richtig weiß das ist richtig im werk
also man hat ja von novartis in ein
altes werk gekauft und umgebaut
eigentlich hatte man gerechnet mann ist
ende februar macht man das ende märz
fertig frühestens und auch nur bis ein
bisschen kleiner
jetzt hat man auch mit hilfe der
bundesregierung das alles ein bisschen
größer gemacht auch mit den zuständigen
behörden in hessen muss das gut geht
muss das gut geklappt haben man kann
richtig produzieren da kommt richtig was
herausfinden
und da kommt ein bisschen hoffnung da
kommt entlastung an der anderen front ab
märz können wir durchatmen ein bisschen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich je das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren